l'horreur une nouvelle fois en algérie
pour le début du ramadan 412 village
bourg ont été massacrés égorgé à l'armé
blanche un premier bilan officiel
faisait état de 78 morts
l'ouest de la france se prépare à
affronter une nouvelle tempête encore
plus impressionnante que la précédente
avec des rafales de vent à 180 km pour
la première fois le gouvernement
intervient dans le mouvement des
chômeurs et des blocs 500 millions de
francs
martine aubry le ministre de l'emploi et
de la solidarité sera notre invité dans
ce journal
jean paul ii se rend dans le centre de
l'italie touchée il ya trois mois par un
séisme des milliers de sans abri
l'attendait dans la région d'assises le
pape et les jmj c'était aussi l'un des
temps forts de l'année 97 avec l'oci
dolly la brebis clonée la disparition de
lady diana et mère teresa ou encore
l'augmentation de la pauvreté l'année en
images valeur avec free fleuve madame
monsieur bonsoir c'est l'un des
massacres les plus horribles jamais
perpétrés en algérie dans l'ouest
algérien la nuit du 30 au 31 décembre
412 personnes ont été égorgés mutilé
assassiné à l'armé blanche ce nouveau
bilan est fourni aujourd'hui par l'un
des plus grands quotidiens algériens le
journal liberté
il y a quelques jours les autorités par
les ailes de 78 morts sur ce nouveau
drame les premiers jours du ramadhan les
détails rapportés par les témoins
retrouvé par le quotidien sont
effroyables jérôme ni les algériens sont
résignés un nouveau ramadan de terreur
dans les rues de belcourt aujourd'hui
c'est toujours l'inquiétude qui domine
rend visite durant le mois du ramadan il
fallait renforcer cette histoire de
sécurité mais finalement je ne sais pas
les journaux font leur titre sur le
dernier massacre celui de relizane avec
des bilans comme d'habitude beaucoup
plus lourd que le bilan officiel
le terme de génocide est repris par
plusieurs articles pour caractériser ce
qui s'est passé dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi dernier
412 morts dans quatre villages autour de
relizane
selon le journal liberté des familles
entières massacrés à la hache et au
sabre les enfants jetés contre les murs
dans les villages de ces mots aride la
peur est quotidienne les jeunes femmes
sont enlevés par les groupes islamiques
armés
les gia pour ce que l'on appelle des
mariages de jouissance avec les
combattants leurs familles ne les revoit
jamais le gros des troupes des
islamistes pourrait bien s'être repliée
dans ce secteur après avoir été chassé
de la région d'alger par l'armée ici les
gia s'affrontent avec la yes l'armée
islamique du salut qui elle a fait une
trêve avec le pouvoir algérien la tuerie
de ce début de ramadhan a visé des
villages favorable à cette armée
islamique du salut ais dans une attaque
à la périphérie d'alger hier soir sept
personnes auraient été tuées en france
l'ouest s'attend à être balayés par une
nouvelle tempête demain un coup de vent
encore plus puissant que le précédent
avec des rafales de 180 km heure et des
vagues de 10 mètres
une nouvelle tempête qui arrive alors
que la bretagne essuie tout juste les
dégâts certains endroits notamment dans
le morbihan sont toujours privés
d'électricité reportage olivier piou et
gabriel camia
je suis fière matin châteaugiron a
changé de physionomie il a suffi de
quelques secondes pendant la tempête de
vendredi pour que la moitié du clocher
s'abattent dans la rue heureusement sans
faire de victime
cet après midi pompiers des entreprises
du bâtiment continuer à parer au plus
pressé
monsieur le curé lui a déjà pris ses
dispositions les salles de théâtre 300
places on va pouvoir s'arranger
et puis ben voyons tout à l'heure et un
mariage à don luis va avoir lieu ici
il a lu à domloup dans la paroisse à
côté et puis des collègues m'ont dit si
tu as besoin tu viens dans les environs
de redondance et un hypermarché qui en
quelques minutes hier était dévastée par
une tornade un tiers du magasin a été
partiellement détruit
alors ce matin dès l'aube les employés
étaient à pied d'oeuvre dans l'urgence
il faut improviser de nouveaux rayons
pour pouvoir ouvrir le vite possible
mais le plus dur c'est encore de
convaincre le client potentiel que pour
l'instant c'est bien fermé les
responsables de l'hypermarché commence à
avoir l'habitude des catastrophes
naturelles leurs magasins avaient déjà
été victimes d'innondations il ya deux
ans
quidam incendie il ya quelques mois là
on aura eu l'ensemble c'est à dire l'eau
le feu est maintenant grand patron
prouvant si c'est forcément compliqué
mais bon bah quoi une brosse de
philosophie en fait c'est toute la
région de redon qui en quelques minutes
il ya un matin a durement souffert
depuis 36 heures les pompiers
multiplient les interventions pour la
seule ville de redon une centaine
d'hommes sont en permanence sur le
terrain dans certaines rues de la ville
passe d'une habitation n'a été épargné
l'électricité revient peu à peu mais
beaucoup de maisons sont plus habitables
et on va chez des enfants ou encore la
journée ont peur on peut encore lire ici
la nuit on a couché là bas et les
bretons ne sont pas encore tiré
d'affaires la météo lance un nouvel avis
de tempête pour demain matin et le
mauvais temps fera bien sûr ailleurs en
europe au large de l'irlande c'est un
pêcheur espagnol qui a disparu et plus
bas en espagne la mer était déchaînée
sur toute la côte atlantique 15 pêcheurs
marocains ont disparu ou là des îles
canaries et de l'autre côté en
méditerranée un marin français s'est
noyé près des baléares
je vous le disais une nouvelle tempête
est attendue pour dimanche sur la
bretagne nous allons donc tout de suite
retrouvé georges penan et art bonsoir
vous êtes le responsable des prévisions
météo pour l'ouest de la france nous
avons vous annoncez un avis de fortes
tempêtes pour demain c'est ça c'est ça
à partir de 8 heures demain matin alors
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ils
veulent avoir cette tempête
oui elle est derrière moi ici elle
n'arrête pas de se tourner sur elle-même
et elle se déplace et elle va
actuellement elle est à peu près à 2000
2500 km de nos côtes et elle va nous
toucher wii vers 7h 8h de la mata
commençant par le finistère donc c'est
la bretagne qui va être touchée à
nouveau tout d'abord c'est la bretagne
mais la dépression va se positionner au
niveau de la cornouaille anglaise entre
la cornouaille et l'irlande
donc le finistère va être touché tous
les abords de manche pour être touchés
dans les zones plus violemment touchés
avec des vents très forts et aussi des
vagues est très importante
alors les vents côté des vents on
prévoit des rafales
de 120 à 140 kilomètres heure dans les
terres et sur les régions côtières
proches de la manche on envisage
nettement plus de 150 kilomètres heure
mais c'est vrai que au delà 150 km heure
les rafales peuvent remonter assez vite
est-ce que les conseils vont pas leur
nez aux gens face à une tempête comme ça
qui se profile c'était des vents très
forts amène des problèmes d'instabilité
pour tous les gens qui circulent
vous parliez du bord de mer tout à
l'heure effectivement nous nous voyons
des vagues de plus de 10 mètres à 500 km
des côtes
donc la houle va déferler demain matin
sur les régions côtières ouest bretagne
littoral sud bretagne et donc il sera
plus que dangereux d'être promeneur le
long des côtes
les automobilistes avec des vents aussi
turbulent parce que ce sont des rafales
quand on dit 150 140 km heure c'est une
pointe assez des ventes qui varie donc
rouler demain me paraît effectivement
c'est un danger en tout cas merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions qui
joue effectivement que le maire de
saint-pierre de quiberon interdit toute
promenade de piétons et véhicules le
long de la côte sauvage
le mouvement des chômeurs le
gouvernement a débloqué comme prévu 500
millions pour l'unedic et l'allocation
de formation reclassement
c'est ce qu'a lancé martine aubry dans
une conférence de presse ce matin nous y
reviendrons dans un instant avec vous
madame aubry mais d'abord les
explications de sébastien guibert et de
vincent meyer 500 millions de francs
pour les chômeurs de longue durée
des consignes claires adressé au préfet
pour mieux utiliser des aides comme le
crs ou le rmi
ce matin martine aubry a voulu à sa
façon répondre aux chômeurs qui occupent
les assedic
rien ne justifie aujourd'hui que ces
actions perdure dans l'illégalité
le mouvement est parti des bouches du
rhône le 12 décembre dernier des
antennes assedic comme celles ci sont
occupés par des chômeurs et des
représentants d'associations qui les
défendent
à arras brive arles saint brieuc
champigny les revendications sont les
mêmes plus 1500 francs pour tous les
minima sociaux et une prime de fin
d'année de 3000 francs pour tous les
chômeurs
on n'est pas là pour perdre leur père on
adapte ont demandé à l'import on en a
marre d'en toucher 2 millions par mois
y'en a marre des cellules de crise sont
mises en place dans les préfectures
mais pas question de verser une prime
automatique les dossiers sont étudiés au
cas par cas comme ici à arras sur 250
chômeurs 197 toucheront une aide
exceptionnelle de deux mille francs en
moyenne
insuffisant répondent les associations
de chômeurs pourtant le ministre des
transports jean claude gayssot leur
annoncé hier soir des tarifs allégés
pour les chômeurs de la région
parisienne marche d'un longue escaliers
à continuer à gravir jusqu'à la gratuité
le mouvement des chômeurs n'a pas faibli
ce soir 13 antennes assedic et un centre
d'action sociale sont toujours occupés
cette annonce a donc pas suffire
désamorcer le conflit les syndicats et
les associations impliquées dans le
mouvement y compris la cgt l'estiment à
suffisante et la douzaine de caisses
d'assedic qui était occupé le sont
toujours
reportage à marseille de jacques cardoze
et vincent décembre partie d'une prime
de noël les chômeurs des bouches du
rhône pourrait bien arriver à d'autres
revendications
après 21 jours d'occupation des locaux
leur détermination ne s'est pas altérée
bien au contraire
cette prime de 3000 francs ils en font
une affaire de principe
mais les chômeurs réclame aussi un
changement de considération et
d'attitudes à leur égard si le travail
massive manabu lui ici un frein au nid à
peu près pour rien alors soit il ya une
véritable politique pour l'emploi
et s'il n'y a pas ça ben on va quand
même revenu mais que c'est mais qu'on
arrête qu'on arrête de nous de nous
traiter de cas sociaux de d'exclus
serait après tout on n'est jamais que le
résultat du système mais pas des exclus
si on est au chômage c'est parce que le
système génère gré du chemin pour
fonctionner parce qu'ils n'ont rien à
perdre parce qu'ils représentent et pèse
de plus en plus dans la société
c'est sans emploi veulent aussi pouvoir
dialoguer participer aux négociations
qui les conservent une table ronde avec
les élus avec le comité chômeurs mais
ces messieurs y aille
on y long on a vu un table ronde mais à
deux vitesses on parle d'abord avec les
élus et non pas que les élus dit
ce qu'il pense c'est après on évite les
comités chabert lors d'une conférence de
presse cet après midi à marseille le
comité chômeurs a jugé les propositions
faites par martine aubry
insuffisant elle a presque parler pour
ne rien dire ah si ce n'est pour parler
pour pas répondre à la revendication
logique des da selon le fait du prince
c'est eux qui va choisir les pauvres
qu'ils aident les pauvres qui les aide
pas les sans emploi ajoute que c'est le
chômage qui devrait être considérée
comme illégale et non pas l'expression
des revendications qu'ils génèrent alors
madame aubry bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
cette conférence de presse était prévue
un peu plus tard je crois vous l'avez
vous l'avais anticipé à cause du
mouvement j'imagine n'avais pas
l'impression d'avoir tardé à réagir
cette conférence de presse ce matin
c'était simplement dire comme je m'y
étais engagé il ya deux mois maintenant
dire à chacun ce que faisait le
gouvernement aujourd'hui pour lutter
contre les exclusions et pour
accompagner les chômeurs de longue durée
vous savez ces occupations le montre
même si elles sont limitées 14 assedic
sur 700 je crois qu'il faut quand même
rappeler son fer l'ampleur pour le coup
des causes d'assedic oui mais y avait
les fêtes de noël et séraphine voulant
dire un mot tout à l'heure bon au-delà
de ces mouvements qui sont limitées je
crois qu'il faut rappeler mais chacun le
sait aujourd'hui que prend un numéro un
des français c'est le chômage et que
derrière ces mouvements derrière les
violences des jeunes on voit bien
l'angoissent de ceux qui sont au chômage
m'angoisse de ceux qui ont peur de le
devenir ou des parents pour leurs
enfants tout simplement un peu plus
dense tous ces gens qui imaginait bien
évidemment et ça je crois que le
gouvernement l'a bien entendu puisque
derrière le premier mise depuis que nous
sommes là depuis six mois
la priorité est donnée à l'emploi et à
la lutte contre les exclusions ce que
j'ai redit ce matin c'est que en
relançant la consommation et donc la
croissance
et vous avez vu les chiffres de cette
fin d'année la production industrielle
qui augmente de 9% les offres d'emploi
qui augmentent de 20% à l'anpe il ya des
premiers signes en créant les emplois de
demain
les nouveaux services les nouvelles
technologies les aides aux pme en
partageant mieux le travail
l'objectif central que le premier
ministre a fixé c'est la lutte pour
l'emploi
parce que si vous permettez je voudrais
dire que la première revendication des
chômeurs c'est d'abord d'avoir un emploi
pour nous c'est notre combat est sûre
c'est bien sûr un travail mais est ce
que c'est vraiment discours qu'ils
attendent aujourd'hui parce que vous
vous dites c'est un mouvement
assez réduit vous dit même que c'est un
mouvement illégal et ça les inquiète
beaucoup
disons les choses simplement bien
aujourd'hui à ce qu il vous à relais des
faits il est aujourd'hui 14 assedic qui
sont occupés des 700 qui ne le sont pas
mais il ya derrière ce que nous savons
c'est à dire cette angoisse des français
qui est notre combat permanent
bombardements n'égale une question
simple lors de l'évacuation l'épopée le
3 2 minutes pour l'emploi mais aussi
pour accompagner tous ceux qui sont dans
l'exclusion car dans le fond dans ses
mouvements il ya des mains tendues et
quand il ya des mains tendues parce
qu'il ya la détresse parce qu'on peut
pas payer une pige électricité parce
qu'on peut pas payer une note de loyer
et bien le gouvernement a pris des
mesures d'urgence
au delà de la politique qu'il mène pour
lutter contre les exclusions la grande
loi que nous prétoire pas rond pour
revaloriser ce que nous avons fait les
minima sociaux pour remettre les
contrats emploi solidarité les
entreprises d'insertion vers les
chômeurs de longue durée c'est ça qui
nous demandent au delà de cela nous
avons pris des mesures d'urgence pour
des cas individuels qui en ont besoin
voilà ce que nous avons dit alors
maintenant revenir sur les
revendications louis qui sont celles des
chômeurs la question déjà sur
l'occupation des assedic plus aller
mendier ou pas l'évacuation qui s il ya
eu 6 6 eva questions qui ont été faites
personne n'a entendu parler je pense que
c'est au préfet d'apprécier en fonction
des risques qu'il ya des preuves de
sécurité en fonction surtout de la gêne
que ça cause d'autres chômeurs notamment
la la con ça va être la rentrée puisque
on sait ce qu ray allen pe aux assedic
et qu'on a besoin de venir pour toucher
aussi de l'argent les préfets
apprécieront mais c'est pas le sujet
sensible mais le sujet essentiel ouverte
savent que la détermination majeure du
gouvernement c'est de lutter contre le
chômage les premiers résultats ténue
certes mais commencent à arriver là
qu'on france confiance revient dans
notre pays
nous accompagnons ceux qui sont les plus
en difficulté nous allons accompagner
des exclus de la santé du logement de
l'emploi dans la grange à des
revendications concrètes qui sont celles
de chômeurs depuis quinze jours qui
s'exprime au fur et à mesure et sociale
ce qui occupe les acides de cercle fermé
témoin je veux dire que la revendication
essentielle des chômeurs c'est l'emploi
takeshi notre détermination voyez la
fameuse prime de fin d'année 3000 francs
de fin d'année de début de nouvelle
année etc
écoutez d'abord illégitime ont d'abord
s'occuper revendications auxquelles
gouvernement
à laquelle gouvernement n'a pas à
répondre car il s'agit du prince
d'indemnisation du chômage qui est
traité par les partenaires sociaux au
sein de l'unedic il ya un conseil
d'administration qui se réunit mercredi
mais ce que le gouvernement a voulu
faire c'est répondre aux mains tendues
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure car
c'est vrai qu'il ya des cas de détresse
et alors qu'on se réjouit tous de voir
que les ventes ont augmenté à noël et
bien des familles rouge au n'ont pas pu
offrir de cadeaux il m'a dit mais comme
vous les faire parler préfet ou encore
la quinta regard sur le premier préfet
au mieux autour de la table l'unité bien
sûr les conseils généraux les communes
les fonds d'action sociale pour aider
des demandeurs d'emploi qui sont en
situation de détresse car là c'est la
réponse humaine mais je dirais que la
réponse du gouvernement c'est une
réponse plus structurelle qui vise à
créer les emplois n'ya relations entre
opérateurs une autre obligation
importante froid qui revient là aussi
tout le temps c'est l'augmentation des
minima sociaux 15 cents francs augmenter
ses minima sociaux quand on gagne de
1200 francs je crois c'est pas beaucoup
quand même pour vivre est ce que ça vous
paraît là aussi quelque chose de normal
se croit qu'il faut augmenter un sens
d'une association venons d'annoncer
l'augmentation des minima au 1er janvier
nous avons augmenté la pl de 3% ce qui
n'avait pas été fait depuis 1994 nous
devons vous nous venons d'annoncer une
augmentation de l'allocation spécifique
de solidarité que touchent les chômeurs
qui ne sont plus indemnisés de 3%
là maintenant et nous accueillons
favorablement une proposition de loi
communiste qui va permettre à tous ceux
qui ont 55 ans 40 ans de cotisations
d'avoir 5000 francs par mois + 1750
francs par mois s'ils touchent
aujourd'hui cette allocation de fin de
droits
l'association solidarité ou le rmi donc
vous voyez que dans le champ qui est le
nôtre et dans l'urgence nous répondre
aujourd'hui aux questions qui nous sont
la revente poursuit je vous propose de
voir un petit peu ce que dit monsieur
robert gibbs qu'on a vu que ce mouvement
était soutenu par les verts par le parti
communiste
autrement dit par votre majorité
plurielle robert hue a envoyé un
communiqué de soutien aux chômeurs
je vous propose de voir comment il a
réagi à ce que vous avez annoncé ce
matin je crois qu'il faut aller bien
plus loin
d'abord les chômeurs ils veulent
effectivement cessé cette aide
nécessaire et qui leur revient je crois
que c'est légitime mais mais ils veulent
surtout que l'on apporte des réponses
aux questions de l'emploi
ça veut donc dire que la question qui
est posée principalement elle prend déjà
tournure avec le plan emploi jeune
avec des 35 heures mais il faut aller
bien plus loin aujourd'hui en matière
d'emploi est allé à des réformes
structurelles et nous sommes là au pied
du mur il faut il faut partir du
principe que la majorité plurielle et et
pourriels et donc il y a deux dents des
composantes qui font entendre leur point
de vue il faut les écouter je je moi je
souhaite que la gauche réussit soyez
vous tous la remarque que je fais sur la
réorientation de la politique européenne
sur le référendum comme l'assurent les
mesures structurelles pour le chômage
elle ne vise pas à diviser jeu elle vise
à l'unité je suis pour la construction
je suis pour que la gauche réussisse
c'est ça qui me conduit aujourd'hui à
faire ces propositions alors on parlera
peut-être de la pression monsieur robert
hue sur le référendum sur le traité
amsterdam mais sinon c'est difficile qui
peut fois d'avoir une majorité plurielle
qui s'expriment comme sa façon un peu
non je dis ce que dit robert hue je
pourrais le dire est une prémisse le dit
la priorité numéro un à notre action
c'est l'emploi et il faut ouvrir toutes
les nouvelles pluies attendues que 10 kg
en majorité mais je ne je ne sens pas un
nom soutien de la majorité sur ce que
nous faisons sur l'emploi et nous
verrons dans quelques jours dans la loi
sur les 35 heures comme nous les avons
vus sur les emplois jeunes comme nous
l'avons vu sur le rétablissement de
l'aide une meilleure égalité entre les
les prélèvements sur les revenus du
travail et du capital dans les réformes
de la sécurité sociale ou du budget 1998
mais nous allons aussi le voir quand
nous ferons voter la grande loi sur
l'exclusion l'année prochaine
comme lorsque nous décidons de remettre
les contrats emploi solidarité vers les
plus fragiles ce qu'a dit robert hue je
le partage maintenant la détermination
une remise à plat complète enfin il la
cgt le fait beaucoup de du système
d'injection du chômage est ce que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut faire entre
hans et les partenaires sociaux qui a
récemment n est pas du tout au
gouvernement d'interviews ceux qui en
sont responsables
ils se réunissent mercredi et je ne me
permettrais pas d'intervenir dans un
domaine où la cgt est d'ailleurs aussi
partie prenante et où ils sont tous
autour de la table pour décider ce qu'il
en est le gouvernement a pris quant à
lui ses responsabilités pour ceux qui
sont sortis d'indemnités de chômage en
ai parlé avec les revalorisation de
l'allocation spécifique solidarité avec
l'ensemble des mesures que j'ai pris ce
matin pour un t1 insisté sur l'insertion
des chômeurs de longue durée et des
rmistes pour le reste c'est vrai qu'il
ya des assedic occupée je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la détermination du
gouvernement
elle est totale les mesures d'urgence
ont été prises donc il faut que ce
mouvement s'arrête il faut que chacun
j'avais responsabilité que vous feriez
mieux nous réunir tous pour combattre le
chômage ce que nous essayons de faire et
je crois d'ailleurs que dix jours moi
mes résultats encore une fois vont
arriver nous donner raison à propos du
chômage toujours elle ce n'est pas
l'option ce conflit aussi c'est le
révélateur d'autre chose s'appelle qu'on
a qu'on a un coin un mouvement de
chômeurs qui se structure qui s'organise
aussi petit soit-il comme vous le dites
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi un état du
chômeur qui a tendance à se pérenniser
en france aujourd'hui et qui fait que
les revendications sont les mêmes
qu'avant vous avez raison
le chômage de longue durée c'est ce
qu'il ya de pire c'est ce qui fait qu'on
se sent détruit qu'on ne se sent plus
une place dans la société qu'on se sent
plus dignes d'appartenir à cette société
c'est la raison pour laquelle bien que
nous ayons consacré beaucoup d'argent
sur les emplois jeunes et la durée du
travail
nous avons souhaité avoir un budget qui
donne la priorité aux chômeurs de longue
durée par les crs par les crédits sur
l'insertion c'est tout cela que j'ai
rappelé ce matin nous nous devons d'une
solidarité la plus grande possible avec
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui au bord de la
route c'est peut-être ça aussi j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui aux chômeurs
qui sont dans les assedic
ayez confiance battez vous avec nous
nous construisons actuellement une
société où il y aura plus de croissance
plus d'emplois et moins d'exclus c'est
en tout cas nos priorités voeux pour
l'année merci madame aubry l'afflux des
réfugiés kurdes en italie continuent
d'inquiéter les autres pays européens la
france a décidé de renforcer ses
contrôles aux frontières il faut dire
qu'au cours des dix derniers mois quatre
mille kurdes en situation irrégulière
ont été interpellés en france contre
seulement 224 l'année précédente le
reportage d'olivier theron et de là dans
la frontière italienne
comme elle n'existait plus depuis un
mois et demi depuis l'entrée de l'italie
dans l'espace schengen les bureaux ont
été rouverts cents crs sont venus en
renfort des fonctionnaires de la ddiss
idec la police des frontières
le gouvernement français réagis
ostensiblement face à l'arrivée massive
de réfugiés kurdes d'irak et de turquie
sur le territoire italien
ces derniers mois nous avons noté
connaissances importantes de clandestins
irakienne kurdes
nous avons travaillé d'ailleurs sur une
filière d'immigration avec nos collègues
italiens et environ trois semaines et le
démantèlement de cette filière
effectivement on a noté une augmentation
de la pression irakienne kurdes
les kurdes qui arrivent par bateau
traverse l'italie et doivent aussi
traversé la france avant de rejoindre
l'allemagne
les points de passage voie ferrée ou
autoroutes sont connus de la police des
frontières qui patrouillent en
permanence vous avez l'italie du secours
de son côté les clones est arrivé par là
et quelques points avant d'enfourner ne
pas faire nous avons en france des fois
ils continuent à piller une fois en
france les clandestins kurdes eux se
changent ils laissent tous les vêtements
et les objets qui permettrait à la
police de prouver qu'ils arrivent
d'italie afin d'éviter d'y être
renvoyées comme le prévoient les accords
de schengen 5000 kurdes dont la majorité
en provenance d'irak ont été arrêtés en
france en 1997
le gouvernement italien a déclaré qu'un
grand nombre de kurdes eux pouvaient
prétendre au droit d'asile à ce moment
là c'est toute l'europe de schengen qui
s'ouvrirait pour les kurdes
il ne serait plus en situation
irrégulière le problème ne pourra donc
pu se régler aux frontières mais par une
prise de position de l'ensemble des pays
européens sur la situation des kurdes et
dans le centre de l'italie le pape s'est
rendu auprès des victimes du séisme de
septembre dernier dans la région
d'assises un séisme qui avait fait 12
morts et près de 30000 sans abri
philippe rochot et jacques gerin le pas
et hésitant mais le geste est sincère
jean paul ii faisait là son cinquième
voyage à assise non plus pour des
rencontres oecuméniques mais pour
apporter son soutien à cette région
d'ombrie temps éprouvée par le
tremblement de terre qui depuis le 26
septembre ne cesse d'y effectuer la
région la présence à ses côtés du chef
du gouvernement romano produit est
peut-être le signe que l'état s'apprête
à aider à la reconstruction
jean paul ii est passé sous les fresques
de la basilique saint-françois salue le
pape
il a voulu se recueillir devant la tombe
de saint françois qui reposent ici
prière pour les victimes mais aussi pour
que la basilique soit restaurée et
consolider après le tremblement de terre
jean paul ii avait commencé sa visite
par le village de hann me faut un
l'épicentre du séisme
la population doit vivre dans des
containers les gens ont peur nous
voulons d'abord que la terre arrête de
tremblay dit cette femme
hier encore on a enregistré une secousse
de degré 6 le fait de ne pas pouvoir
encore penser à la reconstruction
humilie les gens alors que jusqu'à
présent il était habitué à vivre avec ce
tremblement de terre à travers ses
femmes et ses enfants jean paul ii a
voulu surtout rendre hommage aux
quelques quarante mille victimes de ce
tremblement de terre et leur redonner un
peu d'espérance
la venue du pape permet d'attirer
l'attention du monde sur notre sort mais
je dois dire que les autorités de l'état
ne nous ont pas abandonnés
jean paul ii s'est excusé de n'être pas
venue avant mais at il dit je ne voulais
pas gêner les secours
il a voulu partager pendant quelques
minutes la vie quotidienne d'une famille
qui habite dans un container et dont la
maison a dû être détruite comme celle de
centaines d'habitants d'une marche de
l'ombrie qui ont perdu aujourd'hui tout
espoir de cette visite du pape on
retiendra surtout la volonté de jean
paul ii d'être partout présent la
williams isère et détresse mais surtout
ce voyage s'inscrit dans une ligne de
conduite précise et b les nouveaux
pauvres dans les sociétés
industrialisées en afrique au burundi
plus de 7000 personnes ont fui la zone
de l'aéroport de bujumbura la capitale
attaqué la nuit de la saint sylvestre
par des rebelles hutus
l'attaqué aurait fait plus de 200 morts
essentiellement dans la population
civile
isabelle steiss
des visages d'enfants mutilés à coups de
hache et de machettes des rescapés du 8
sanglante au burundi la nuit de la
saint-sylvestre 284 morts des centaines
de blessés pour la plupart des femmes et
des enfants
les victimes d'une nouvelle attaque de
la rébellion hutu à quelques kilomètres
de la capitale bujumbura par milliers
ils ont fui les massacres pour se
réfugier dans des camps otages
d'affrontements militaires dont les
victimes ce sont eux les civils
le président burundais pierre buyoya
accusent les rebelles hutus de faire
alliance avec leurs frères d'armes au
rwanda pour déstabiliser le régime
et au-delà la région au burundi comme au
rwanda voisin
c'est la minorité tutsie qui est au
pouvoir depuis 1993 94
mais les extrémistes hutus sont loin
d'être vaincu les red se multiplient les
chiffres sont effrayants cinq à huit
cent mille tutsi rwandais exterminés en
deux cent mille morts au burundi la
recrudescence des affrontements menace
d'enflammer toute l'afrique des grands
lacs
comme chaque soir maintenant me faisons
un arrêt sur l'année écoulée comment a
t'on vécu 97 entre les journées
mondiales de la jeunesse à paris les
progrès de la génétique avec la brebis
dolly ou encore l'émergence des
questions d'environnement philippe
lefait a dit claude bec
1997 inscrit cette fin de siècle dans
l'absence de repères ainsi la belle de
lits ruminants d'exception et
reconstituer sans seuil et sans
fécondation à partir d'une cellule de
brebis lé nez clown et de savants
écossais après 278 échec
cette avancée scientifique ouvre la voie
à des progrès pharmaceutiques majeures
mais laisse se développer l'effrayant
fantasme du clonage humain
déjà condamné ou interdits en occident
les thérapies multiples n'en finissent
plus de produire leurs effets le sida
reste mais recule par avant je vivais
dans le présent 3
et maintenant je réfléchi en termes
d'années a pas d'un d'été en a pas
d'interpréter à venir ici le bilan est
de plus en plus accablant 90% des 30
millions de victimes et seulement 20% de
l'argent de la recherche
le sida mais aussi la tuberculose pour
l' oms
il y as alerte rouge
disparu également un homme entièrement
paralysé qui dictent d'un singulier
battement de cils le livre d'une vie de
mutants il meurt à 45 en 1997 chacun
cherche sa voie
très affaibli jean paul ii n'a rien
perdu de sa force d'attraction
les journées mondiales de la jeunesse
sont un succès imprévu le discours du
bien et du mal fédère plus d'un million
de jeunes dans ce monde complexe
on cherche des cinq les vraies celles
que consacrera le droit canon les autres
celle de substitution emblématique d'une
époque quand elles ne suffisent plus
l'extrémisme de certaines sectes celle
de la porte du paradis aux états unis
poussent au suicide ses adeptes à la
veille d'une rencontre fixée sur
internet avec une soucoupe volante
en france dans les rues de février des
dizaines de milliers de citoyens
trouvent une vertu à la désobéissance
civile non loi debré la gauche et morale
et pétitionnaires être libre est la
maison sans avoir à les dénoncer
la société française devrait encore
faire face à sa violence à l'occasion de
plusieurs faits divers maltraitance
inceste pédophilie l'opinion redécouvre
ses déviances départ coule ses pages
aurait eu confiance en lui mais chapeau
jam rapstar sous la plume des
sociologues la violence à l'école est
rangé sous le terme générique
incivilités le ministre allègre lui
oppose la leçon de morale et la maison
correction si la violence était à
l'animal dans les quartiers difficiles
on continue de jeter des pierres sur les
bus d'incendié les voitures et le
pitbull est toujours une arme par
destination comme dit la justice
l'historien aurait pu retenir de cette
année que le français cohen tannoudji et
nobel de physique ou que les russes avec
la station orbitale mir invente le
carambolage spatiale le grand frère
américain fournira une aide mais le
commandant de bord russe est dit-on en
sérieuse dépression juillet ici mars à
80 millions de kilomètres à
photographier si loin la planète rouge
rocchi robot télécommandé américain
devient un héros comme un autre ailleurs
l'asie brûle et suffoque la forêt de
sumatra et de bornéo disparaît dans la
sécheresse et la bêtise gouvernementale
pendant ce temps en france l'écologie
entre au gouvernement elle stoppe le
canal rhin-rhône fait fermer le
surgénérateur superphénix sans savoir
comment le démanteler
et pour la première fois paris se donne
à la circulation alternée 1997 le vrai
le seul le repère durable la misère ce
seul exemple en corée du nord la disette
s'incruster devient famine est à nos
portes
l'urgence faute de politiques globales
s'incruste quand les restos du coeur
distribue 61 millions de repas un expert
estime que 7 millions de personnes
subissent la dégradation de la situation
de l'emploi
parmi elles les sdf contre la pauvreté
la misère là bas jamais je ne
comprendrai comment font certains pour
arriver plus loin
assis raide et le cheminement levée de
cette dame on retiendra qu'elle appelait
ses fans mais fragile comme cette fin de
siècle
je n'ai pas posé de questions assez
étrange série mais alors quand j'ai
compris le retour des vacances de noël
la circulation était relativement dense
avec quelques bouchons cet après midi
sur l'autoroute a6 et dans les vallées
alpines
mais les professionnels de la montagne
se frotte les mains ce début de saison
s'annonce prometteur aussi bien dans les
alpes que dans les pyrénées où les taux
d'occupation des stations de ski ont
atteint les 100% reportage à val louron
de christophe la rocca et olivier combe
ce pourrait être un proverbe pyrénéen
quand la neige est bonne la saison est
bonne et quand sa guise comme ça
la fortune est presque là + 30 % de
fréquentation à val louron
il n'y avait cet après midi qu'à
regarder le terrasses des cafés et les
sourires les commerçants pour comprendre
que pour l'instant tout va bien
là les gens sont satisfaits de leur
séjour je pense parce qu'ils ont passé
de bonnes fêtes et sa venue pour se
retrouver en famille dans un petit coin
des pyrénées près de près de la nature
qui est omniprésente et sur la station
de val louron et là je pense qu'ils sont
satisfaits de leur séjour satisfaits et
pas ingrat dans certains commerces le
chiffre d'affaires a fait un bond de 45%
par rapport à noël dernier
c'est bien simple pour la semaine du
jour de l'an on n'aurait pas su faire
mieux
on a eu un très bon taux d'occupation
sur la seconde semaine des vacances de
noël puisque la totalité des logements
de la vallée du louron et aient été
coupés bien sûr il y a les
inconditionnels des familles pour la
plupart qui viennent chaque année les
bonnes comme les mauvaises l'a21 n'y
avait pas du tout une mèche et les
enfants ont fait du deltaplane et ça
j'ai trouvé ça très très sympa avec un
pisteur qui a une école de deltaplane
donc même si a pas de neige
il ya toujours des possibilités mais
cette année les stations surtout réussi
à capter la clientèle volage celle qui
n'hésite pas à s'envoler
les destinations exotiques je m'étais
reims nigeria de moins importante une di
roma tout le dit que là qu'il n'existait
pas sur le soleil s'est pas surtout ça
qui fait la marque lui des compagnies
donc c'est vrai que ça fait des budgets
une semaine à 4 senna me font alors que
pour beaucoup beaucoup moins cher on a
eu un beau soleil en arrivant la
poudreuse en milieu de semaine et puis
au soleil pour finir extraordinaire je
dirais même plus magnifique c'est le
grand cri d'amour de josiane balasko
amour pour le théâtre et les comédiens
un grand cri d'amour c'est le nom de son
nouveau film inspiré de la pièce qu'elle
avait écrite et dans laquelle elle
incarne nos côtés de richard berry un
couple de comédiens qui se retrouvent
sur scène quinze ans après s'être séparé
stéphane haumant et bernie mes coups de
gueule et coups de théâtre
pas facile de monter une pièce quand les
vedettes se détestent hugou retrouves
jiji quinze ans après leur rupture
balasko retrouves berry avec lui elle a
déjà joué à un grand cri d'amour sur
scène et pendant deux saisons dans la
vraie vie vous ne vous ai testé pas mal
heureusement j'avais pu jouer 250 points
sur cetet détester et tournait ensuite
un film sera vraiment été franchi et
baal 11 et on reprend sur fait une
entrée très volontiers à condition qu'il
me présente des excuses
quand on insulte les gens la moindre des
choses c'est de s'excuser
non mais t'as pas insulté le juge vous
avez échangé des propos un peu vifs
c'est tout héron vierge veulent prendre
comment es tu commences à me chier dans
les bottes
j'ai jamais vu une [ __ ] pareil là je
te le dis en face à kaunas
si vous placez un but de maggio naples
et donc chacun leurs qualités mais je
crois que j ai quand même obligé très
soupe au lait et au homard tient le
personnage que joue richard il a le
verbe est haut et oui ils insultent
ensuite alors que j j -ph
tu peux pas laisser tomber
deuxième chance pour toi tu étais agacé
c'est la joie mais pense à ta carrière
38 ans sous la comédie perçu une
angoisse celle des acteurs vieillissants
rêvant de leurs succès passés avec les
applaudissements pour raison de vivre
une autre des handicapés en garde
oui cet acteur un grand cri d'amour
vache ces deux là ne le savent pas mais
ils s'aiment encore femmes dont j'ai été
amoureux fou après le père noël des
bronzés nuit d'ivresse
le café théâtre au cinéma c'est devenu
une habitude un huit clos servi par des
comédiens généreux et un rythme endiablé
je vous rappelle les principaux titres
de ce journal l'horreur une nouvelle
fois en algérie pour le début du ramadan
412 village où ont été massacrés égorgé
à l'armé blanche un premier bilan
faisait état de 78 morts
l'ouest de la france se prépare à
affronter une nouvelle tempête encore
plus impressionnante que la précédente
avec des rafales de vent à plus de 180
km heure et des vagues avec des creux de
10 mètres pour la première fois le
gouvernement intervient dans le
mouvement des chômeurs et des blocs de
500 millions de francs martine aubry le
ministre de l'emploi et de la solidarité
invité de notre journal réaffirme que
l'emploi reste la priorité du
gouvernement et souhaite aussi la fin
des opérations des caisses de sécu
voilà dans un instant vous allez
retrouver isabelle martinet pour la
météo qui vous parlera de l'avis de
tempête surtout le l'ouest à 20h50 rabot
iard demain 7h dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra carole laure et
lewis furey et puis amylin entre l'élite
michèle cotta recevra à la madeleine
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver à
20 heures demain
bonne soirée se tromper
il sortait vous